[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
Juan Pablo lucumís con nosotros en el
estudio Juan Pablo bienvenido buena
mañana de martes y vamos a comenzar
hablando de los datos del producto
interno bruto de china en el 2022 Cómo
le fue al gigante asiático Buenos días
Raúl Pues los datos no son nada
positivos el crecimiento económico de
China cayó a su segundo nivel más bajo
en al menos cuatro décadas entre otras
cosas por sus estrictos controles contra
el Coby 19 y una fuerte caída en el
sector inmobiliario hablamos de fuertes
caídas porque el crecimiento económico
de 2021 fue del
8,1% para 2022 se esperaba por lo menos
un 5,5% y en cambio el pib fue de tan
solo el 3% menor a las previsiones y muy
por debajo de los datos del año anterior
china aseguró que el resultado de su
crecimiento responde a una situación de
crisis mundial escuchemos
el entorno internacional actual sigue
evolucionando de manera complicada el
impulso de crecimiento de la economía
mundial se está desacelerando la
situación del comercio mundial no es
optimista y la economía mundial puede
enfrentar una estanflación la base para
la recuperación de la economía nacional
no es lo suficientemente sólida Y
todavía hay muchos desafíos para la
producción y operación de las empresas
nos vamos ahora a Juan Pablo vástago
Suiza donde se desarrolla el segundo día
del foro económico mundial así es y
seguimos hablando de china porque la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bounder Legend propuso hoy la creación
de lo que llamó un club de materias
primas críticas entre la Unión Europea y
países como Estados Unidos Reino Unido o
Canadá para contrarrestar el monopolio
chino monder Legend dijo que el objetivo
de este Club sería fortalecer las
cadenas de suministro de occidente tener
una diversificación y alejarse de
proveedores únicos como Rusia en China
la presidenta de la comisión europea
también aseguró que el bloque de los 27
será mucho más contundente a la hora de
contrarrestar las prácticas comerciales
desleales y que no dudará en abrir
investigaciones se considera que los
contratos del bloque están siendo
distorsionados por subvenciones de China
Border Legend acusó al gigante asiático
de subvención armasivamente las
Industrias de la Unión Europea y
restringir el acceso a su mercado Esto
fue lo que ella dijo
china ha estado alentando abiertamente a
las empresas que consumen mucha energía
en Europa y en otros lugares a trasladar
toda o parte de su producción lo hacen
con la promesa de energía barata a bajos
costos laborales y un entorno
regulatorio más indulgente al mismo
tiempo china en gran medida subvenciona
su industria y restringe el acceso a su
mercado a las empresas de la Unión
Europea en anuncios importantes para
América Latina habló de concluir
acuerdos comerciales con México y chile
así como de reabrir debate con mercosur
Juan Pablo y continuó la reunión de los
ministros de economía de la Unión
Europea Así es el euro grupo se ha
mostrado optimista para limitar la
inflación Pero ha debatido sobre la ley
de inflación de Estados Unidos que
amenaza a la economía del bloque
previamente nuestra corresponsal en
Bruselas Esther Herrera nos dio más
detalles
la ley de reducción de la inflación de
Estados Unidos ha sentado como un
auténtico jarro de agua fría a la Unión
Europea porque considera Bruselas que es
altamente discriminatoria entre otras
cuestiones Estados Unidos prevé ayudas
millonarias a la compra de coches
eléctricos Pero siempre y cuando estos
sean producidos en Estados Unidos la
Unión Europea considera que esto puede
afectar gravemente a la industria
automovilística europea Después de
varios meses de discusiones en que
Bruselas ha pedido excepciones al igual
que tienen los coches de Canadá y de
México Estados Unidos a finales de
diciembre dio su brazo a torcer a medias
en que aprobó que los coches europeos o
comerciales Se podrían beneficiar de
esta ley algo que Bruselas vio como algo
positivo en cualquier caso la Unión
Europea ya está preparando un gran plan
para hacer frente a esta ley Pero
siempre y cuando se evite la
confrontación con Estados Unidos evitar
una guerra comercial a toda Costa aún
así la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula ha hablado en el foro económico
de davos en que ha avanzado un gran plan
industrial de energías limpias en que se
va a ayudar a la inversión de energías
limpias y también mejorar la
competitividad de la Unión Europea
también habrá una reforma de las ayudas
de estado para que los países puedan
tener más fácil ofrecer ayudas públicas
en la inversión de industrias limpias y
paralelamente la Unión Europea ya está
preparando también la creación de un
posible fondo soberano en que ayude a la
competitividad y a la industria europea
todo esto se va a abordar en una Cumbre
extraordinaria de líderes europeos a
principios de febrero en que se va a
abordar esta cuestión especialmente
porque países como Francia y Alemania
están pidiendo una respuesta Clara y
firme europea ante esta nueva ley
indicadores económicos
y por eso iniciamos con Asia las
acciones cerraron en terreno mixto con
el indicador de Tokio reportando
ganancias las pérdidas llegaron luego
del anuncio de la caída del pib de China
las bolsas en Europa siguen operando
mayoritariamente a la baja pendientes de
las tensiones en la economía de Reino
Unido y muy atentos a los anuncios del
euro grupo Así es Juan Pablo Muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información económica más adelante más
ahora regresamos